y
[Música]
ah
en ecuador las comunidades indígenas
utilizan los saberes ancestrales para
enfrentar el commit 19 en los pueblos de
la amazonía ecuatoriana están
convencidos de que lo han conseguido y
lo ratifican con la baja mortalidad a
causa de la pandemia preparar una receta
con la corteza del salud acá aspirar a
una planta que considera muy poderosa
mezclada con ajo jengibre y otros
ingredientes
louis hierven durante 20 minutos se lo
toman fermentado en un fuerte licor de
caña de azúcar en araujo un pueblo de
3.000 habitantes a las puertas de las
selvas de la amazonía aseguran que viven
sin temor a la pandemia en la provincia
de pastaza los indígenas también
decidieron no acudir a los hospitales y
curarse con este brebaje que califican
de abrasador y tonificante cuando pasa
por la garganta en los poblados de la
amazonía los indígenas viven sin
mascarillas sin restricciones de
movilidad o de entretenimiento a pesar
de obtener pruebas científicas ellos
aseguran que son energizantes
espirituales que fortalecen el sistema
inmunológico para ellos no es una vacuna
pero ratifican que la tasa de mortalidad
en la amazonía está en el 3% frente al
88 por ciento de la media nacional
[Música]
en perú la mayor parte de los pueblos
indígenas carecen de medios para
defenderse al cove' 19 es por eso que
muchos recurren a la sabiduría ancestral
a través de plantas medicinales como
único recurso para combatir al
coronavirus y preservar la vida de sus
pueblos
ellos inhalan el vapor de un preparado a
base de eucalipto matiko ajo como cambur
jengibre achiote quiebra luisa
manzanilla y limones
precisamente en la región ucayali un
grupo de jóvenes indígenas se inspiró en
la medicina ancestral del pueblo shipibo
conibo y creó el comando matic o kobe 19
acompañados de un chamán examinan a los
enfermos y les suministran este
preparado y luego les dan de beber un té
preparado con la planta matiko que
señalan tendría propiedades antivirales
antimicrobianas entre otros ellos
afirman que la medicina de sus ancestros
es eficiente y aseguran haber sanado a
más de 500 pacientes las autoridades de
este país firmaron un convenio con la
república de la india para revalorizar
la medicina tradicional peruana se busca
que las terapias utilizadas por las
comunidades indígenas y sus insumos
naturales pueden unirse a la lucha
contra la pandemia del corona
[Música]
en un panorama donde piden mayor
atención por parte de las autoridades
nacionales los embera panameños una
comunidad indígena ubicada en la
provincia de darién ha optado por la
medicina natural para enfrentar a su
manera el coi 19 una preparación de
hierbas propias de sus tierras que se
introducen en agua hirviendo y luego se
inhala y se bebe según ellos ha sido una
cura efectiva para el virus los embera
son una de las cinco comarcas indígenas
que son oficialmente reconocidas en
panamá que por su ubicación geográfica y
el acceso a los servicios básicos han
sido más vulnerables en esta época de
pandemia escuelas e instituciones
públicas han servido para aislar los
casos de personas positivas en las
propias áreas donde viven y cuando
existió la necesidad por la gravedad de
los enfermos se han trasladado a las
grandes ciudades
[Música]